the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors
danced away my birthright before the war
house targaryen counted 18 dragons
by the end we had two and nearly as few
targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
update video
alright folks things are beginning to
get very exciting now because hbo has
officially started to hire actors to
star in their new
upcoming series house of the dragon
these rumors have been circulating
around the internet for several months
but as of yesterday
they have officially hired their first
actor patty considine who will star in
one of the lead roles
as king viserys targaryen let's go ahead
and have a look at one of the reports
from deadline to see what it says about
this breaking news
the headline reads house of the dragon
patty considine to star as king viserys
targaryen and hbo's game of thrones
prequel series
this actor who is also the co-star of
the 2020 hbo series the outsider and the
third day
will lead the cast of house of the
dragon the network straight to series
game of thrones prequel from george rr
martin
ryan condell and miguel sibochnik based
on george rr martin's fire and blood
this series which is set 300 years
before the events at game of thrones
tells the story of house targaryen in
the 10-episode first season
considine will star as king viserys
targaryen
chosen by the lords of westeros to
succeed the old king
joharis targaryen at the great council
at harrenhal
a warm kind and decent man viserys only
wishes to carry forward his
grandfather's legacy
but good men do not necessarily make for
great kings
house of the dragon was co-created by
george r martin
and ryan condole the pilot's script that
landed the series order was also written
by ryan condell
he serves as co-showrunner alongside
game of thrones veteran miguel
sapochnick
who will direct the first episode as
well as additional episodes
george rr martin ryan condell and miguel
sapochnick executive produce alongside
vince gerardus
and sarah lee hess who has joined condo
as a writer on the series
now i know this article only says miguel
sapochnick may direct some of the
episodes but i have read several other
reports that say he will direct the
entire first season
which would be very exciting he has
directed some of my favorite episodes in
game of thrones
now i will say i'm not very familiar
with the actor
patty considine but my girlfriend and i
did watch hbo's show the outsider
based on one of stephen king's novels i
thought the show started off great
during the first three or four episodes
but then
i thought it went off the rails a little
bit near the end however
i thought paddy did a decent job with
his character and i will say i am very
interested in seeing how he does as king
viserys targaryen
after all hbo is known for casting the
same actors and several other shows so i
am not surprised to see them bring him
back for
another role in another series now i
know there has been a lot of rumors
lately about the viking star actor
travis fimmel joining the cast on house
of the dragon
as of right now this has not been
confirmed
i know some game of thrones channels
like to spread around fake news by
saying whatever they want is confirmed
but it's not the case
at least not yet i for one would love to
see him in house of the dragon
he is already in one of the series for
hbo max called raised by wolves so there
is a good chance hbo will bring him back
for another series
my girlfriend and i have actually been
watching raised by wolves as well
and we both think travis has done a
great job in that show since he was so
amazing in vikings i think he can
definitely do well in another series
that's similar in a lot of ways
i believe he would make for a great
member of house targaryen but for now
we will just have to wait and see if it
actually happens or not
let's focus on what we do know is
confirmed now that we know they have
hired someone as king viserys the first
we can assume house of the dragon will
not show us aegon the conqueror
and his sisters i actually think this is
really unfortunate because it was
something i really wanted to see get
brought to life
i always thought if they're going to
show us the history of house targaryen
then they should start when the
targaryens first arrived in westeros
what they are giving us is still very
exciting because now it looks like we
are definitely getting the dance of the
dragons
this should also make for an amazing
show that i know i cannot wait to see
who had never fastened his riding chains
stood
in his saddle he leapt from his dragon
to aemons
and in his hand was dark sister the
valyrian sword of aegon's sister queen
visenya
as eamonn one eye looked up in terror
daemon ripped off his nephew's helm
and drove the sword down into his one
remaining eye
so hard the point came out the back of
the young
prince's throat half a heartbeat later
the dragons struck the lake sending up a
couch of water so high
that it was said to have been as tall as
harrenhal's great
tower the lake boiled with dragon blood
and then was still now i have given a
brief description of who king viserys
targaryen was in another one of my
videos but just in case you did not see
that video
let's go over some of the details about
this character now that we know we will
definitely
see him in the show let me just bring up
a wiki of ice and fire so i can try to
keep this short and sweet
for those of you that don't know viserys
targaryen was the fifth targaryen king
to sit on the iron throne
from 103 ac to 129 ac
in case you didn't know ac means after
aegon's conquest
therefore this viserys targaryen was a
king
a little over a hundred years after
aegon conquered westeros
viserys targaryen succeeded his
grandfather
the old king jeharis the first viserys
continued the prosperous peace and
legacy of his grandsire
however the seeds for the civil war
known as the dance of the dragons would
much later engulf the realm
were inadvertently sown in his reign i
am assuming the show will lead us right
into the dance of the dragons
another thing you should know is this
viserys was a dragon rider
who rode belaryon the black dread until
the dragon died of old age during the
reign of jiharis the first
viserys never bonded with another dragon
after belarion's death
so although we may not see aegon the
conqueror
we may see his dragon balerion and it's
crazy to think his dragon outlived him
by a hundred years
viserys was known as someone who hated
conflicts
he was described as amiable open-handed
and eager to make others happy
though viserys was never considered
strong-willed he was not indecisive
either
when he made a choice he was unwavering
and firmly stood by his decision
viserys's generosity was legendary and
the red keep became a place of song
and splendor during his reign viserys
hosted countless balls
feasts and tournaments and lavish gold
and offices and honors among
those he favored he was well loved by
lords and small folk alike
in his mid-life viserys's stoutness
caused him numerous health issues
including from gout aching joints and
respiratory issues
near the end of his life his girth
almost kept him from ascending the steps
to the iron throne
yikes now i think i will make a separate
video about the dance of the dragon so i
won't go into that here
i want to save that for later so i can
focus solely on that one major event in
westerosi history
so get ready my friends now that casting
is underway
it won't be long before they start
filming these episodes and like i've
said before
once they start filming we will begin to
see what will actually happen
in the new series that's when photos
will start to leak from the different
sets
as always i will be here to make videos
on every bit of information that gets
released
make sure you subscribe so you join the
rest of us on the journey
if you would like to see a video on the
dance of the dragons then let me know
down below
i want to thank everyone for watching
the video if you would like to get early
access to my videos consider signing up
for my patreon account
that link is in the description anyways
i hope to see all of you back here for
my next video
have a great day i will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you